Everyone knows about Elon Musk’s
companies, Tesla and SpaceX.
But few know that he also co-founded OpenAI.
In the few short years of its existence,
OpenAI has become one of the world’s leading
artificial intelligence research labs.
It ended 2022 with a bang….as millions
of people signed up for ChatGPT.
Its question-and-answer computer program
is so popular that some schools have
banned it to prevent students from cheating.
It took just one second to write me a poem about
strawberry cheesecake in the tone of Shakespeare.
Another OpenAI tool generates art. I typed a few
words, and DALL-E 2 produced
these beautiful designs.
OpenAI’s futuristic research laboratory is housed
in this historic building in San Francisco.
It's a small company with
only around 400 employees.
But it's making huge advances in AI.
Everything it’s working on involves
mimicking human intelligence by analyzing
tremendous amounts of data on the internet.
The sheer amount of computing
required is incredibly expensive.
A professor in the University of Maryland’s
Computer Science department estimates
ChatGPT costs $100,000 a day to run.
Some feel this estimate is far too low.
AI has been touted as the next big thing for
a while now, but it wasn’t until recently that
the general public began taking it seriously.
OpenAI was only founded in 2015 as a non-profit
platform by Musk and CEO Sam Altman.
Clip I think AI will be a technological
revolution on the scale of the agricultural
or the industrial or computer revolution.
Before starting OpenAI, Altman was
the president of the venture capital
company Y Combinator which helped launch
Airbnb, Reddit, Twitch, and many more.
Altman and Musk teamed up with legendary
Silicon Valley investor Peter Thiel and
LinkedIn co-founder Reid Hoffman and
pledged $1 billion toward the project.
OpenAI’s current investors include Microsoft,
which is reportedly now investing
$10 billion into ChatGPT.
Microsoft says it willl roll out ChatGPT on its
own AI service, Azure OpenAI. Companies like Al
Jazeera use Azure for translation services.
Could ChatGPT breathe life into Microsoft’s
struggling search engine Bing and
give Google a run for its money?
Could it replace traditional
search engines altogether?
Google CEO Sundar Pichai is supposedly taking
the threat seriously. He has reportedly told
staff to focus urgently on developing
AI products.Google researchers revealed
they were able to transform a few still
images into a 3D reconstruction of a scene.
Google is competing against
a young and nimble company.
This is what the first day at the office
looked like in early 2016. Pretty barebones.
The small team has come a long way,
but there’s still a long way to go.
ChatGPT sometimes gives answers that
are misleading or downright wrong.
I asked it to solve this riddle:
Timothy’s mom has four sons. Their
names are North, South, and East.
What's the name of the fourth son?
ChatGPT says it’s West. But the answer is Timothy.
Altman warns that “it’s a mistake to be relying
on it for anything important right now.”
But he does have high hopes and says future
systems will make “ChatGPT
look like a boring toy.”
The changes are coming fast.
OpenAI’s president tweeted:
2023 will make 2022 look like a sleepy
year for AI advancement & adoption.
Musk responded to Greg Brockman
with a single word: Yikes.
There’s a lot packed into that word.
Musk has warned about the dangers of AI for years,
equating it to “summoning the demon.”
Here’s what he told CNBC in 2014.
I'd like to just keep an eye on
what's going on with artificial
intelligence. I think there's optentially
a dangerous outcome there. Dangerous?
Potentially. How so?
I mean, there have been
movies about this, you know, like “terminator”.
In the movie “terminator,” they didn’t expect,
you know some sort of Terminator-like outcome.
While Musk may be worried about advances in
technology, ironically, his companies rely on AI.
Tesla is inching toward the full self-driving
finish line thanks to AI.
Musk insists Tesla’s most valuable
product ever could be its AI-powered bot.
His chip company Neuralink wants to sync
the brain with artificial intelligence.
Musk resigned from the board of OpenAI
to avoid any future conflicts because of
Tesla’s work in AI. He stayed on as a donor
and advisor. (2018, three yrs later)
He insists he’s making sure AI is
used for good, not evil.
OpenAI’s website states
that its mission “is to ensure that artificial
general intelligence benefits all of humanity.”
Artificial general intelligence is the
ability to learn any task that a human
can so that faced with an unfamiliar task, an
AGI system can still figure out what to do.
So what’s in store this year? Hey Alexa,
tell me what will happen in 2023.Sorry,
I can’t predict the future.Well, AI personal
assistants could get a lot smarter.
One prediction is that AI
will replace a lot of jobs.
Artists are already fearing for their livelihoods.
This AI-generated artwork even won an art
competition in Colorado last year. (in 2022)
However, the World Economic Forum estimates AI
will actually create millions more jobs than it
destroys, with high demand for machine learning
specialists and data analysts.
As we look toward the future,
OpenAI’s next-generation version of ChatGPT is
highly anticipated and could appear in 2023.
And how about an AI that generates 3D models where
you type in a few words, and the program creates
what usually takes animators hours to make?
OpenAI announced the 3D tool Point-E in a
research paper last year. It’s still a work in
process, and 2023 could see further developments.
What OpenAI has shown is that a small dedicated
team can change the world quickly.
Even if the road ahead is difficult.
The CEO of OpenAI recently tweeted
about the importance of resilience.
Altman wrote:
“You’re supposed
to pour your life force into something
and it’s not supposed to always be easy.”
In the future, artificial intelligence will,
at the very least, make things look easy.
Despite the economic meltdown we all faced in
2022, it's clear there are still innovative
companies on the rise. And while OpenAI is
showing promise, one unicorn fintech startup
is delivering booming returns right now.
And the media is raving about it.
Masterworks has unlocked the potential
of contemporary art.A $1.7 trillion
alternative investment that used to
only be available to billionaires.
With Masterworks, everyday investors can enter
the high-end art market without spending millions.
Why art?
Contemporary art has outpaced
the S&P 500 by 131% over the last 26 years.
While the markets were getting crushed in
2022…Masterworks saw 11 artworks deliver returns
to investors in the tens of millions of dollars.
Over 617,000 people have signed up
so far…including many of my viewers.
And you can sign up now to create a free,
no-obligation account at
the link in the description.